depends on the person because growing up
I'm obviously not skinny I think there's
Beauty so growing up my answers are
changing now
thank you
foreign
[Music]
do you think most girls are objective or
do you think they think they're hotter
than they are
or do they underwrite themselves go
around personally I think it depends on
the person because growing up I'm
obviously not skinny hi everyone I'm not
skinny so growing up I was never the
beauty standard for anyone so like all
my friends were getting chatted up by
people blah blah blah blah and I was
just the other one you know so like I
never really thought of myself as
an attractive person like I would never
call myself anything more than a thought
but now like I don't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like I've
grown into myself and I've I've I'm
comfortable with who I am now that like
even if I you guys call me delusion or
whatever I think I'm maybe not 10 let's
not go that far but like definitely an
eight per so like whether you guys think
I am or not yeah that's got nothing to
do with her but like what is it that
took you from a four to an eight if
nothing's changed what is it that takes
loving myself and and looking in the
mirror and not being disgusted at what I
see I understand that yeah so but that
doesn't you're you're not necessarily
being objective about how other people
view you right because isn't that what a
rating really is like what you think the
vast majority like like if I rated
myself one to ten I give myself a five I
think I'm normal looking and I I just
think it's based on my results I think
if I was in eight nine or ten I would
have had modeling contracts because
people in the top 20 of beauty they get
they get modeling contracts what is
beauty so what what is beauty I mean
there's a lot of things like if you
I mean you can you can go online and
have people rate your pictures and they
rank you one to ten that's wild and and
so you can get you can get a lot of data
that says how attractive you are in
society and men will wait you women will
rate you like every day how we look is
like how we represent ourselves it's not
fun but it's just like being honest
so
um and it's also like you can take a
dating apps to like you know everyone's
tender Bumble like they have a ranking
for you behind the scenes
yeah down yeah well I trust so
um I don't understand when girls say
like I'm an eight because or sometimes I
hear girls say time because I hear this
a lot where they say like because I love
myself and I'm like confident now but
don't you think attractiveness is based
on results
they may be but I don't care about those
results
to be honest
but do you think then you're not being
objective about your how attractive you
are or how attractive anyone else might
be
um
I guess not but like yeah
that stuff's not really important to me
but I think when when someone when
someone rates somebody why why does that
have anything to do with them like if
you rape me if someone rated like
somebody a three and it's just like okay
that's that's your opinion like it's not
like a rating is not a fact it's an
opinion what do you know what I mean
everyone's opinion then well yeah add up
to a consensus maybe not a fact like
consensus yeah consensus yeah yeah but I
think
like I I have a group of friends right
and when I walk into the room with a
group of friends I know immediately
who's going to get the most attention
from the guys it's it's not me right I
have like a friend who's like very very
attractive and I know when I walk into a
room with her like the guys talk to her
first because like girls you can kind of
just feel it but I almost wonder when I
hear like and I hear this from girls a
lot like I'm a 10 I'm a 10 I'm a 10.
um if that's not like rooted in reality
because attractiveness like there's
numbers behind it whether it's just your
results in the world or your dating app
data or
the like the type of guys you can get
so the question is can you find a man
that can stand next to me and deal with
me yeah but when you say that's your
value to him who's that yeah for me I
don't I don't know
like when you're selling something she
talking about cars when you're selling
something it's you you decide the value
of your you know the market the market
does so so okay that's like me saying
okay I'm Envy like an NBA why an NBA
player that's like that's like that's
like okay stop stop interrupting me
that's that's like me saying that I can
get a top one percent guy so I would say
I deserve a guy that can that can that
makes half a million but none are lining
up to buy me then I'm not I'm not worth
that that's your value and so so you
can't just tell men oh I'm still just as
well you need to tell nothing but you
just did you just went off
she's not getting my point and I'm gonna
repeat I'm gonna repeat clearly so I
know very clearly what I want okay now
as as you said probably I'm not
available so I don't want to get what I
want cool I stay by my horn I don't need
a man like oh I get what I want I guess
I can just say buy my own I don't need a
man I don't know the other child I'm
like a person I'm not a baby machine I'm
not uh you know what I mean like that's
my values I stand by my own for what
you're saying you don't sound very happy
about that no I just don't I'm not very
happy about how another other women can
think about our body and our Essence
I didn't I'm telling you what men want
yeah but you can you can think in your
way and that's that's perfect
I've talked to thousands of men yeah
some men approach her and then she's
saying the value that she brings to the
man that is approaching her whether he
chooses to go to her or on once or 20
whatever obviously he's approached us so
he likes her so that's the value
the question is is that fair to expect
monogamy so I'm saying over a certain
age you're less valuable to men and then
as soon as I say as soon as I say that
you guys get triggered no no no and you
guys you keep you keep interrupting this
is this is my this is this is this is my
this is
no no no I'm saying stop stop stop stop
this is rude this is my show it's very
rude to interrupt the host okay so so
yeah sorry like this is disrespectful
sorry carry on and so I'm saying that if
you're going to men and telling them
what they should value and every time I
say this is what men value you guys you
keep arguing with it then you want to
say well what are my best years this
this this and this I get that but I'm
just saying she asked the question and
said that this girl said she's 30 and
then you said you're 30. so when you get
to 30 you made it personal about her but
I don't know why no no sorry I don't
know yeah she said once she gets to 35
and then her eggs blah blah blah she
asked her something personal about her
so that's why it got personal because
you made it about honestly that's why
she was talking about herself and not
saying that you expect all men to accept
this value blah blah blah the point is
if if a certain man approaches her and
this is the value that she gives or she
brings and the Guides of want it then
that's fine I can understand that you're
saying that this is men want XYZ men
want
um whatever you said from a certain age
or whatever as if to say no man
approaches a 30 or 35 year old woman
when there's two 30 year old women sat
here who men approach but there's a
difference between like four set like
like it doesn't count unless you're
getting a ring none of it counts yes it
doesn't count yeah it doesn't it doesn't
yeah it can be approached your number
can be taken your Instagram can be got
but if you're not being kept it doesn't
matter fair enough you can tell any man
I get moved to 10 times a day cool all
right do you have a man no maybe we
don't I remember because we don't want
men like the majority of the men okay so
it's not about you taking women it's
about we like each other we find you
know the match so you cannot talk about
wema as someone they've been taking yeah
but again
I learned something today yeah yeah
auntie we me and Auntie had a
conversation RT explained to me I said
are you in a relationship she said yeah
I'm in a relationship and I said does
that so does that mean you're not part
of the 35 and over leftover women which
was a topic that we were speaking about
at the time and she went I'm still part
of that category and I said I don't get
it like you're in a relationship you've
you've made it and she went no I have
I've got I haven't got a ring so I'm
still a part of that category and I
didn't get it because I was like why
you're in a committed relationship you
where you well actually all because I'm
in a committed relationship I'm a
leftover oh I'm a leftover in a
committee relationship yes that was it
and that's what I actually said and even
when he was talking about the value the
difference with now is that yeah at 25 I
was hot
do you know me I was hot slim hot
that's nah you are that is fully myself
I look hot for somebody of 53. yeah I
mean but act fooling myself that I look
as hot as I am at 53 as I did at 25. no
I'm just the obsession is that the same
man that I was with at 25 is the same
thing that I was with now do you know I
mean but other than that no and I agree
that and I'm not fooling myself to say
that you know I mean I was lucky enough
that he had my best years and he's still
got my best years and I had his the best
years but at the end of the day I can't
turn around and say I'm better off at
anybody else at 53 because anybody else
at 53 mostly got a wedding ring on
they'd be married or something like that
by the end of the day if it weren't for
a fluke I'm just like everybody else
yeah I'm a leftover in a committed
relationship and that's what women feel
to realize that yes before you think
about oh I'm going to be single I'm
going to be this and I'm going to be
that you've got to fix yourself you know
what because before I started thinking
like that I was like you know I've got
to get my pension I gotta get my own
house I gotta get the house done in case
I'm disabled I gotta get my will go get
my LPA because just in case you end up
on your own and you know something 32
years and I'm still got that mindset you
know what because I'm still left over
because I've still gotta think like that
so I'm going to affecting myself yeah
I've been with the guy for like 30
something years I got I gotta still
think about that you know what because I
don't know you're doing the right thing
I've got to fool myself and say I've got
the same Worth to him as I was years ago
or I look you know I mean oh yeah you're
a hot come on 53. well the goal is
marriage then is that the goal should
always be marriage because that's when
you know a guy is committed to you and
that's why I said you can be a woman for
today I was talking the other week and I
was saying a man could be with you for
30 years 40 years 50 years whatever so
there's a ring on your fingers not
committed to you you can step out so you
said you've been with the same person
that you've been with since you were 25
no before that yeah since you were
before 28 and did you have kids or no we
got two separate children you've got two
so you've not had kids together now
since since you no we haven't okay
that's interesting yeah and I can go
around and say oh yes when I was 35 I
look really good and we could try and
have children together come on by the
time you're 35. you picked yourself yeah
I could better get up 35 of him but then
you've got to think to yourself how old
am I going to be when I got the kid goes
Nursery am I where I'm gonna be winning
I'm gonna go and pick up my grandkids
now I don't want to be going picking up
my child and they say who's that is that
your grandma no it's my mummy and then
nowadays you're thinking about secondary
school or university I don't want to be
in those 70 years old I'm going to
picking up my child and say oh yeah they
graduate and you're playing with fire
because
um the average if you want to freeze
your eggs and go that route like that it
costs like twenty five thousand dollars
there's no guarantee it'll work the
average person can't afford that no I'm
just thinking it's interesting because
you said you were together from before
you were 21st so what like 22 23 about
that 22 23 and then but you you were in
the like you guys said the best years of
your life whatever and still didn't have
kids still having them
sorry you're still I'm still having that
no no I'm just going by what these I'm
saying by the word by the worst from the
they said I wouldn't have a child from
35 onwards so according to a man if a
man wants to have a child and that that
would have been the time to get to have
a child then not like 30 Because by the
time 30 comes we're like forget it you
know what I mean forget it because I'm
putting my body through that and buy a
pod according what um say your name
again KB KB he said especially when a
woman has a child with the before
that's the best year also because this
has very strong a close relationship
between you know the your your baby uh
dad and yourself right so but you are
actually just showing that that's not
true so yeah because the differences you
don't know my story the difference is is
that I had an abusive relationship
that's why I've got no Hangouts there's
a completely different if it was a happy
relationship and I had my son and we
left
um that'd be different but number one I
was on contraception when I had my son
so he wasn't planned and because of that
reason that's why I decided to have one
child because I would say one is the
mistake two can say is an accident three
is careless four and above your white
list
so as far as I'm concerned I had one out
of wedlock and that is it yeah but
anyway you add a child and your partner
evaluate you anyways as a valuable
valuable women so he actually spent
after the best here with you in this
scenario
no I mean yes
what you guys saying it doesn't happen
yeah
what they're trying to say is that if
I'd met him at 30. why should he be
faithful to me when I've given my best
years to some other man if I stayed with
my baby father yeah until I was 30 and
then said you know what I'm gonna get
back with the first one the one I'm with
now why should he be monogamous why
should he stay with me because you have
a lot of stuff no why do you why do you
think you're an 11 if like being a 10 is
you're perfect
so do you do you think you're perfect
no I think there's Beauty in
imperfection you know Perfection is not
uh why are you talking over me no I'll
say this glamorous Beauty and there's a
difference anywhere
I believe that I'm an 11 out of 10 just
because I can and I'm allowed yeah that
way and I genuinely believe perfect
I was not done talking
um I genuinely believe that Perfection
is not real but there's Beauty and
imperfection and I think no like you're
you're very attractive like I think
you're like I think you're attractive
can you let me finish
so what I'm saying like like to me I
would never say I'm a 10 because like a
10 is like perfect and I don't think I'm
perfect so I I get kids like is that but
we were saying looks wise right yeah and
I genuinely see myself as genuinely
beautiful I genuinely see myself as
someone who is a goddess because at the
end of the day
Society is what decides on beauty
standards right right and I can I don't
have to follow that beauty standard
right I genuinely believe that I'm
beautiful yeah well and I'm not taking
that away from you I just like I just
could I just could I just could never
say like I wouldn't say you're perfect
you know what I mean yeah yeah and
that's and that's what I mean I'm just
playing around yeah I think I'm really a
10 out of 10. like genuinely I feel like
I'm a 10 out of 10. yeah I take care of
myself what has given you that uh my
looks we were only talking about looks
yes we were talking about personality or
skill or anything like that is is that
based on the way people have treated you
throughout your life no this is based on
how I was raised and how I view myself
and how I've worked hard to see the
beauty that I deserve to see so I worked
so you see an 11 out of 10 Beauty I
wouldn't bro it's a joke
yeah like I just said I consider myself
a 10 out of 10 for sure so you think
you're up there with so who would you
see in like the media that's like a 10
out of 10. why are we going based off of
media people no like why does that
matter well because because on society
well because that like society's Beauty
Supply I don't give a [ __ ] about Society
that's the key here is that I I have my
own Viewpoint right like okay so who
would you class as a 10 out of 10. what
apart from yourself well because like
you're not really in order in order to
scale someone one to ten someone has to
not be a ten right so so I fully agree
with that yeah and so but but we asked
what I think I am what she thinks he is
what you think you are I'm not going
based off of anybody else except for
what I see in the mirror right so but
then like that almost wouldn't be a
scale that like because then you have no
way to mess with [ __ ] right okay so
it's like your way of rebelling against
the scale almost forget Rebellion it's
just genuinely how I feel like and I'm
not saying like I like again like I
think I think you're beautiful like yeah
but it's just something
for you to say that you're a five out of
time right but I just think I live like
are you comparing her to you because I'm
not making a comparison in her own right
she is
she would say she's attending yes but
like you're in her own room but I just
think if I was if I was a 10 I would
have had modeling yeah
sorry we talking about programs
but do you know what I'm saying like I
think if I was like a 10 right then I
would have had model it I would have had
modeling contracts by now I would have
had people I would have had results to
show that I would have had NFL NBA
players but remember that is all based
on beauty standards that are set by
that's based on reality I do like that's
society that's reality and like but I
don't see the same way that other people
do though yeah let me ask the question
do you think there's an objective Beauty
standard yes
can you describe objective to me as in
like what the Baseline okay something
like an objective Society Beauty Center
so for example art is there good art or
is all art the same
I feel like that's kind of different
because art art is also something that's
all about perspective yeah it's
subjective yeah but in in in in if you
look at Medieval buildings especially
Americans notice this when they come
here they love our Asian architecture
right compared to their architecture
there is a standard that's and like a
stick figure versus like Picasso
I guess um when it comes to that you
know art is something that you put time
and skill and detail into I can't really
say the same for people no because my
point is that as as generally human
beings can identify what's Beauty and
what's not
in the society yeah but even because
Society has a standard of beauty yeah
exactly yeah because we can identify a
good architect a good uh beautiful
building than a standard one yeah and we
do the same with beauty yes exactly
again that's just what we consider
aesthetically pleasing like when it
comes to people I can't really do that
because but you can do it yourself
though we can choose how we build a
building but we can't choose how we look
that much we can only do so much to our
appearance to change ourselves and then
into the and fit into the beauty
standard on top of the fact that the
beauty standard has changed so much I
want this sort of disagree agree with
that because you look at the Kings and
when they had all their concubines you
can definitely guarantee they have to be
the finest women in the land to be the
Kings
so there had to there's always been a
whether we like it or not an objective
standard that this man of power
I think the reason for this conversation
like myself in India happened is that
there seems to be in these days and
times a
female delusion
about
how you view yourself and I think men
generally are a little bit more
realistic as the way they view
themselves and okay now my question is
why are men so obsessed with humbling
women why is it why does it hurt so much
to watch a woman love themselves and
genuinely believe that they're 10 out of
10 even though according to society
standards I'll give you an answer to
that one I think it's more of a reaction
because they've tried to do the simpish
behavior being a nice guy and they're
just being flawed for it so they're
overreacting to it that's probably
what's happened I don't think it's that
I think that when you interact with
people right you generally try to gauge
the type of person that they are do you
you know what I mean like women
generally tend to think that they are
higher right than other people and it's
like well just calm down but that that's
egotistical versus just confidence I
think what it is I think it has to be if
you have a a actually it's an illusion
it actually really wants to say real
quick I'm sorry question for you Jessica
so if you if you um if you had a guy
coming around and saying like I'm a like
a 10 in terms of my income so in terms
of like like I Get Money I get this
bread even though he's like broke would
you would you would you not would you
not like look at him like a little
delusional
I probably would but that's because we
can actually gauge that properly right
but wealth we can actually measure
properly due to I'm not done talking
damn we can't properly get we can
properly gauge wealth though according
to the living standards of whatever
state or country we live in argue and
say that if a [ __ ] got two
dollars in his bank account he says he's
a 10 out of 10 I'm gonna be like that
argue it's not Society that's saying
that two dollars ain't a millionaire
could you not the guy not argue that no
but we've actually we've actually put it
away
two dollars you've got two dollars bro
we actually are able to put a value on
that but we as a society do not do not
have a right to put a gauge on beauty
but they do Chaska but that's no that's
I never said
the day I'm just saying that I can't I
don't see it this time that's why I'm
saying like I feel like like when you
say that it's not that because you
actually think you're perfect it's
because it's because you think like you
don't like societies like beauty
standards and it's kind of like your way
of rebellion we think I'm beautiful but
then you are question me on it and the
only way that I can answer is the way
that they can understand because when I
start saying like because I think I'm
beautiful but they're like why why do
you think you're a 10 out of 10. what is
it that makes you out of 10 out of 10
and it's like well but like the thing is
like it's weird though because I feel
like girls do this to guys all the time
like I think it's also I think that
girls like if a guy says oh I can get
girls I can get [ __ ] and like we
don't think he can we'll humble him
and it's kind of like we will that's
what I'm saying like even even you kind
of like we're trying to do that to Sarah
earlier
it's a double standards
it was a little outlandish for him to
ask me what I rate him because at the
end of the day I was talking to you
would you rate me I think you're allowed
to believe whatever no no no wait wait
wait each other
rate each other oh Jesus go rate each
other
rate each other
she's thinking I don't want to give him
too much gas
she's trying to go through the whole
thing going she's going Jessica my neck
hurts
please all right you for your age
I'm an eight okay cool okay now rate her
chip five really you give her a five no
joke I just wanted to be so wrong I
can't get mad at you you're an eight
you're you're an eight okay but
genuinely you're not you're not an
eleven
I'm trying to speak I genuinely cannot
get upset at the way that other people
feel about my physical abuse yeah I'm
not done talking oh my goodness maybe
put down the alcohol for a good minute
anyway I genuinely can't get upset when
other people feel the way that they do
about my appearance whether they think
I'm a one or a ten because beauty is in
the eye of the beholder I like I mean
it's like facial symmetry so I actually
like agree with what he gave you like I
would probably give you seven eight
because your your face is very
symmetrical okay and I bet like you've
probably had a modeling contract at some
point I I was a freelance model I
haven't uh yeah that's what I'm with
that's what I'm saying because like I
rate people eight to ten and you could
get a model I I don't really give seven
so I think like if you could I don't I
try not to because I like it's based on
someone else came up with this but like
I just thought it made sense so like
eight to ten is like you could make
money off your looks five six you can
that's why I don't give myself above a
set like above a six that's why I say
five six because I feel like I'm more
pretty cute
but deep down I mean people put lizzo up
on a like pedestal like oh my God she's
amazing it's like
she's just a fat woman
I have to say it and I don't even think
it's like humbling like like you because
you'll see why are you so obsessed with
humbling women right and like even with
lizzo that's what the manosphere is like
favorite person to Humble is I think
yeah and but like it's like sad to her
because like honestly I think she looks
kind of dumb sometimes because people
allow her to like live in this delusion
where she's like walking at 300 pounds
with her butt out and nobody like checks
her like you don't you don't think
that's kind of ninja
um personally like I said I think
everybody has red delusion comes in I
think everybody has a right to believe
that they are beautiful in their own
right because at the end of the day we
can't really do much to change our looks
and even if we do it's like a damned if
you do damned if you don't kind of
society like if we could get all
liposuction done and our face done and
reconstructed but people are still gonna
find something wrong right but when when
it came to lizzo right like I was upset
when she did do the whole like when she
like was courtside at the NBA game and
like her ass this out not because of her
size or who she is as a person or
whatever I was more so upset because
that was not the time to do that like
right the kids be watching basketball
too you know like this this was
inappropriate if she was doing it at her
own concert at her own Leisure we can't
say much because at the end of the day
that's what she wants well I mean it's
okay if she wants to do that I just
think like
people like they're lying like the
people around her are lying to her and
gassing her up like we're friends right
so I would if we if we went out to a bar
and I was and I wore something where
like I just it makes me look heavy
unflattering right I and you don't say
anything to me like are you a real
friend let's see that that's the
difference though is the personal
relationship versus just people on the
internet that like to idealize and
idolize celebrities they like to have
someone to look up to and unfortunately
that women get to be delusional do you
know understand like they get to be like
they get to be lizzo well I think men
don't get to be that delusional exactly
because like because women were like
yeah girl you go listen as a guy if you
came out and guys will check other guys
say bro like
yeah bro yeah you got bogie in your nose
head bro you know what I'm saying that
just get rid of women tend and I said
this on your show before women will lie
to other women knowing that they're
lying to other women and gas that woman
up like lizzo and then she'll be out in
the public eye and then she'll be like
oh I want a high value man it's like bro
like love you're about 300 pounds like
he's not looking for you right he's not
looking for him like you and you might
believe that you are this 11 out of 10
woman right well but you're not well and
it's and to me like I'm just someone
like I'd rather someone be honest and I
and I think like your point is like you
think like women should be confident
because we can't always change how we
look yeah and so I think that's like the
point like that women are like really
trying to get across exactly but like
like men are like it's okay to be
confident but like you guys are
delusional at some point and I think
there's somewhere in like a middle
ground where you can still be confident
in what you have you know what I mean
when women
have these criteria for their man they
pick 20 of the male population generally
eighty percent of women pick in their
head twenty percent of the male
population so if so I'm asking so if 20
of the male population have 80 of the
women to choose from
do you think what that one man is only
going to be sleeping with that one woman
I never saw no one as a woman coming
like oh I need a man you know like uh
please I'm alone all these 80 percent of
women have men and I don't have fleas
and if you marry I accept you I never
saw that no but why are you feeling
about that but this is this is what's
happening so what's happening now is
when 80 of women are sleeping with 20 of
men so women can say oh I don't like
polygamy I would never do that but we
pick the same guy you're already sharing
your guys so when you just go for ugly
men average guys like and I said I said
this on my podcast right average men and
average women are actually missing each
other like they're missing each other
they're missing like a whole beat
because there are average guys like we
talked about earlier on like the guys
that sit down and watch
cornhub and you know like fans those
type of guys are looking for like women
that are just like them right but the
women that are just like them are
looking at the 20 of guys and it's like
yo there's a load of guys here but
you're not looking at them you're
looking at those other guys and it's
like well there's average men there's
average women you need to start
you know pairing with one another you
stop average women need to stop trying
to look for that 20 20 top 20 guy and
that's what I'm saying it would it would
even out a little bit but what happens
is that top 20 guy has all of these
women and the women start saying men are
trash men are trash that top 20 guy has
options
sometimes the exercises I'm not saying
that it's right but sometimes he does
because he's got so many women looking
for him because he knows I said I know
I'm six foot two I know listen listen
there's a load of women looking for a
six foot two guy
but even there's a load of women there's
a lot of men looking for MILFs you know
you know but I'm sorry your options
decrease by 50 by the time you're 30.
you're right it does depend how you look
she looks good she looks real good but
she's still 50. yeah and so what guys
allow Paul to make a point sorry sorry
bro like like it's I'm sorry no you're
okay um the the point is I actually I
don't even I didn't even happen
it's just saying like you're saying you
got called fat when you were younger so
now you're going to call someone else
fat to try and make them feel bad I feel
like that it's not to make them it's not
no no it's not to make them feel bad or
you know maybe maybe they should feel
bad enough to get on the treadmill and
run
yeah
I did I read it look I swear to God I
had I had 200 pounds you know what I hit
200 pounds it was the worst day of my
life and some dude at work like they're
saying oh I would never date a girl over
200 pounds and I and I and I carry the
weight better so like I'm taller right
so I don't think he knew I was and and
so I signed up for a marathon I swear to
God I ran a marathon then I lost their
life then and I lost a bunch of weight
what so you signed up bro because
because I'm not lazy because I was like
oh [ __ ] this is a problem and if you
know what we do instead we say you're
not a whale you look great you're not
fat even though that's it is what it is
and you deserve love that's the worst
one everyone deserves love no one
deserves
you don't think you deserve all right
you earn it you don't deserve it in life
what do you think men deserve then if if
they still deserve love everyone
what is the guy what is the guy that
approached you what did he deserve love
but you know why didn't you give it to
him I said to him I said to him I said
to him I think all women to an extent
have pretty privilege yes
yeah yeah yeah do you think do you think
whales have pretty privilege
wow is it cute you think you think well
do you think whales have the same amount
of pretty privilege that you have as in
the ones in the ocean is that what we're
talking about no I'm talking about fat
chicks no I'm not talking I'm not
calling them that okay
what do women wears let's just stop that
okay fat chicks no big women bigger
bigger women I'm not why can't I call
them what they are
no but I'm saying like why do you want
to live in delusion because they're bad
they have more fat
I'll tell you why you had a different
delusion it minimizes accountability you
can be offended and it can be plausible
at the same time or it can be a
compliment I feel like I feel like you
can carry weight in completely different
way and it will look different on
different people like there's guys right
like it's like you said you're tall who
looks scary who carried in 200 pounds on
you and you still didn't look like you
were that big no I was kind of Wheeling
it so how much does your boyfriend weigh
if we're talking if we're talking about
fat yeah three is a load of girls 300
houses and you'd be like yeah 300.
where's the fat is it in the booty name
one girl that looks good at 300 pounds I
know what 300 pounds is the word obese
you know what 300 pounds is you know
what a fat girl is yeah what is that in
stone
300.
pounds what is that like is that over
15.
oh it's 21 Stone 21st yeah name one girl
that looks good at 21 Stone
that's not a whale I don't know anyone
at 21 Stone so the media I can think of
a lot of plus size models I don't know
does lizard look good because you never
look I think she's cute personally I
think she's cute I don't know what most
men do you think do you think she gets
the same pretty privilege you do I don't
know I don't know I think you do know
you do know I think I think I think if
she will sat next to you when your
boyfriend introduce himself to you I
think you would have felt pretty
confident
yo I have a twin sister right so I I had
this message growing up she's actually
waiting she used to bully me for a bit
because I was like a hippie nice guy
when I was growing up I was like no stay
there's no ego whatever but um why do
you apply different standards for a man
and I would argue maybe because I'm a
man but I argue the standards you have
for men are a lot higher than the
standards you would have for a woman why
why do you have why do you apply
different standards depending on the
gender when arguably if you date both
it's actually about the person
um yeah like that's a really good point
I think because arguably it's just
easier to be a man and so therefore
you're like well it's easy why is it
easier to be a man when man I mean the
gender pay Gap just says it all there
okay but there's also a gap in like men
commit suicide more yeah men are
dropping out of colleges without toxic
masculinity that men can't speak about
so then so then why why are we saying
that there's like a patriarchy when men
have it hard too like why are you just
said you said because you just said
women have it harder than men but if
women had it harder than men like then
why are men I didn't say they had it
harder I just said it was easier to be a
guy then but okay if it's easier to be a
guy then why do more men commit suicide
because they they feel because of toxic
masculinity which are perpetuated by
both men and women they feel like they
have to be macho and I don't subscribe
to that at all I'm very much like um
well it could it be possible that men
have a harder life than women
yeah of course it could be possible of
course it could be okay so that would
like contradict what you said earlier
well this is it it's not black and white
it's not right or wrong yeah gray area
maybe yeah so everything is there's no
like very solid so yeah that's and even
the whole
um Rule and exception there's all it's
not one size fits all it's really not
where there is that's it there are some
men who Thrive and succeed because
they're a man because life is easy
therefore I'd be like I would expect you
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna give you an
example my dad's the half top half a
percentage of earners okay he's the
white man right that but but here's the
thing he worked 80 hours a week my whole
life I didn't I didn't get to see him
yeah how how is that like the patriarchy
when my dad put in 80 hours every week
his whole life from the time I was like
a child right missed a lot a lot of a
lot of [ __ ] like he earned that yeah and
I'm never gonna say that's like no the
patriarchy but now now he's a white male
CEO yeah right so is is that the
patriarchy or did women not choose to do
that well that's the only way we could
argue is the only defense that you could
have is if you had a exact female
replica to be like she likely would not
get where he is that's the only way we
could argue it right but it doesn't want
to take away from his efforts it doesn't
take away so then why do we why do we
talk about it at all if you can't if you
have no no idea why there's a pay Gap
yeah yeah like like it's is it possible
that it's the the industries that women
pick because if you if you have controls
that have more choice so if you go to
like the most egalitarian countries
there's more of a pay Gap rather than
less because women choose jobs with
people
and then use jobs with objects so like
my I'm I'm from a family of ten all the
boys are Engineers none of the girls are
Engineers like is it possible it's a
biological difference rather than a
patriarchy yeah no I think I think well
I think the pay Gap is more like within
so I don't know if you saw on
International women's day they had a bot
that literally showed you the pay Gap
within organizations so obviously women
will tend to go for things like being a
nurse being a teacher yeah they pay a
lot less than being yeah
yes but the pay gut then exists in so a
lot of things where there's a lot of
male actors who will be like I will not
uh sign on to this contract unless I
know my female counterparts are being
paid the same and so I think the pay Gap
then comes and well it's also the tree
it's also the trait like disagreeable
though so as women like we're naturally
more agreeable 100 so so we're I'm more
I'm terrible at negotiating I just want
to make everyone happy and I just want
to be like yeah I'll do whatever for
nothing and
um and but that's like men are more just
agreeable if you look at the
agreeability scale does that make sense
yeah yeah so again like why do we just
assume patriarchy when you don't know if
it's because of different personality
traits and gender differences no and
gender they are so real so in my studies
um it showed that so men are more likely
to go for so let's say there's a job and
a woman is more likely to look at a job
specification and go oh but she's more
likely to say no to herself and she's
more likely to go
um or I don't know if I'm good enough
yeah or as a man is more likely to
actually inflate their ability and be
like I'm gonna go for that and it
actually reflects in relationships where
a man is more likely to actually shoot
above and be like yeah yeah I can I can
yes so it's a reason we see a lot of um
less attractive men with more attractive
women the women are more likely to be
like look I spent a lot of my life being
like I'm a four out of ten I'm I'm
probably about seven but I spent a lot
of my life dating men and people would
be like Amy that guy is not in your
league like why do you not and they're
like they're definitely like you know
out like you're out of their league and
it's actually yeah there's a real gender
difference and
is that biological is it social
um right there that's because men and
men and women value different things man
value looks more women don't value looks
as much they value things like social
status like a blue check mark a blue and
this is yeah I've dated a guy with a
blue check mark right like we like
social status yeah like we'd be lying if
we said we didn't care or whatever it is
like it's it could be height right it
could be like it could be you know maybe
he's not as good looking facially but
he's he makes money yeah or he makes
money yeah right and so that's why we
see there's a gap in that yeah yeah but
we don't we don't scream patriarchy for
like men yeah yeah like but then we
don't know that's it we don't know is it
because of uh so you've got the
biopsychosocial approach
um and that's which is what I tend to um
subscribe to because that's it it's not
easy to be like oh it's just biology or
it's just sociology or it's just your
person my question is like yeah I just
don't even understand like in this day
and age how we are fighting the
patriarchy like what more can they do I
can do any job I want
like nothing has ever stopped me from
doing anything yeah so like I don't even
know like I don't even know what I need
feminism for now okay I can't think of
one thing oh
yeah
are you okay
she's number one missing the point she's
looking at things
really really doesn't I'm sorry she's
going to be in a very unhappy
relationship if she finds that person
it's all based on whatever is exterior
there's there she doesn't care about
anything deeper and that's that's I'm
very I feel sorry for her she doesn't
actually know what's important and
I've I really feel for the men like
guys who have so much they're working so
hard they're trying to prove themselves
because society makes them
because you have to make your way inside
you have to do
so much to prove yourself these days
and to have this girl come here and just
completely belittle you on the internet
these are good men out there
and and they don't just they they they
don't deserve you you don't even deserve
a McDonald's from them
I'm sorry but
you
it's not about the dollar sign it's
about the intention
I would love even if who cares about the
food if a guy takes me to McDonald's and
then buys me a meal
amazing
I love McDonald's
like what's wrong with that it's the
intention it's the fact that he
made made a point and said hey I've got
this
I want to take you out I want to get you
3500 what do you say again leftover
women yep I didn't catch it fully but I
got the general gist leftover thing do
you think that's is that offensive to
you guys I think that's kind of
offensive that's kind of hard
unless it applies for men too I feel
it's quite realistic if money is in that
position myself being okay I'm not past
35 I'm 31 but perhaps I could see why
men might feel that way about me it's
not right I don't agree with it but I
can understand it it's somewhat true and
it's not it's not like a fun reality
like one day I'm gonna be 35. like
hopefully hopefully I'll be married but
I don't know that yeah but like I think
it's honest at least like guys are
attracted to fertility and youth well
that's not really self-love that's like
being super efficient right that's what
feminism has taught people is that if
you love yourself and you think you
deserve that high value man go for it
even if you are not in in that same
caliber or doing the things that you
need to do to be with that man and keep
that man it just has taught taught us
that self self love you can put yourself
in a pedestal and whatever you think you
deserve that's exactly even if it's
astronomical out of this world just
unrealistic it's okay you can do it
because of feminism that's what I think
well and and the other thing I was going
to add is like when you go into a
relationship it's not about you like
it's about like about who got who who
what guy wants to date a girl that's all
about me because most of the girls that
spout self-love are selfish is in my
experience and you guys know but that's
the thing maybe this room is the
exception I don't know but in my
experience like with those girls like
typically it's about me me they don't
have anything to offer to a guy other
outside of hooking up they don't cook
they don't clean they don't like do any
of the things
but the cardi B that's a perfect example
you would say
a lot of these women say they don't need
men and talk down on men in their music
but like back home what are they doing
like cardi B she's like her music I
don't cook I don't clean but yet she's
married she goes back to the cheaters
money she can hired a cleaner
yeah
but that I think that line comes from
like back in the day like women they
were just meant to be doing that you
know and they were just being perceived
as that as Housewives as cleaners as
mothers and shut up and you don't do
anything else and you don't say and you
have no power and that's unfair you know
and that's why I think he came from from
there I don't think it's that deep
personally in regards to those lyrics
she's in my opinion saying I don't cook
I don't clean because I don't have to
like about what what else yeah but let
me tell you how I got this ring right
w-a-p what you're saying is true yeah
back in the day women did take on that
domestic role but for that context she's
basically shedding light on the fact of
you don't even need to be able to do the
things that you should want to do for
yourself forget a relationship a husband
you should be able to do that as a bare
minimum for yourself so yeah
I think it's I think it's about the
culture though yeah because you know
what that song sounds like it sounds
like I'm not doing it for a guy like I I
think we can like try to wrap it around
and that it's not but come on like but
you are very favorite uh in men in a
relationship but I think when you are in
a relationship it has to be go both ways
oh it's not just me cleaning and cooking
it's not just maintaining myself and
it's not just me they're in the house
you know it's both both have to help or
we hired a cleaner but here's the thing
I don't know I said that I go both ways
I tell women leave the bombs if your
guy's not working get out like leave him
like don't don't stay with a bum ass
dude but I think it's both ways like
with women like I have brothers and I I
think it's important that they have
standards for women outside of just
being pretty and like looking nice and
like we should try to earn that the men
that we want to be with men raise a
single appearance single fathers raise
better children exactly than single
mothers so when when they have been
given the chance they've got a better
job exactly yeah I just think women like
we get frustrated like when there's a
problem yeah we just get frustrated and
like cry or get mad yeah I feel and I do
it too like like even even and I kind of
noticed the differences in like the
genders doing like solving problems
because even with like my business like
I'll be doing stuff and I'll just be
like get mad at something and my
brothers will be like okay why don't you
try this this this like they're just
more logical do you think a man would do
a better job raising a girl Than a Woman
yeah
yeah right what about the feminine side
um would she be more masculine then
probably
um I would say like she's probably she'd
probably be a tomboy
it might be hard to find a man my mom
was raised by my granddad so my mom was
had four siblings she's the youngest my
grand my mom my nan ran off different
life then my granddad raised worked has
his own business and raised four kids my
mum it was a single mom
I'm not
blowing it away I'm blowing a trumpet
because she's the best mum raised my
brother me and my sister strong woman
was the breadwinner was everything The
Decorator everything was she shouting a
lot all the time but she did it because
we were bad kids
she's like she was a young mum she had
my brother about 15 me at 17.
but that she got I feel like she got
that strongness from my Grandad because
he was a very strict
working man did everything he played
both roles so I just think it
it differs whereas she was raised by a
man I was raised by a woman so I feel
like I've got both why uh I actually
like this idea that like men raised
children better I would believe that
because they're more logic why more men
is it because of the government because
I feel like a lot of men wouldn't want
100 custody of the child oh no they will
um they want their freedom too no no I
think most men want to be in their kids
lives um I can't remember what the stat
is off the top of my head but one of the
most likely times that a guy is going to
commit suicide is when it's like
post-divorce because oftentimes she'll
take care of the divorce yeah what about
men who not like in marriage-wise yeah
but let's say men who who been in a
relation there's no marriage they just
aren't a child with someone who they
actually 100 because because I feel like
they're very happy with 50 or less
um are you talking about men when
there's no marriage it's just with a
woman
I don't I don't know but like in my
experience most men want to be with
their children even even if it's in a
shitty situation for the most 100 unless
they're like one of those guys that are
just you know shooting up and everybody
but that's not the majority well I don't
think most men are going to 100 because
if you're in if you're alive and in the
child's life why would you want 100
you'd rather do 50 50. well but
personally though a woman that wear
makeup just got no right to tell Amanda
he's ugly
that's natural you ever you ever hear
girls say oh he's medium ugly I'm like
sis that's just your level
[Laughter]
like because girls will sleep with a guy
and they'll they'll think that's their
level but it's not your level he can
commit to you your side chick but what
about the girls that are prettier they
wear a lot of makeup but they're
actually prettier without it on I mean
I'll go through that trouble yeah then
why would they do it I don't know
Society they wouldn't they wouldn't it's
not Society
they wouldn't do it like girls you get
responses based on what you do so they
probably get more attention when they
wear more makeup that's why they do it
so I'm a photographer right so my whole
industry is women men right people
looking good
so there's hundreds of women that look
and okay I guess I'm biased right
because they're models so that they look
good but there's a lot of people out
there that look just as good if not
better without makeup but they still
choose to wear makeup so do you still
think that's fraud absolutely you still
think it's fraud even if she looks
better without it on to you
I've met a girl that says she can't go
out of the house without makeup on
because she'll feel naked
I couldn't find it I just don't
understand that logic just a lot more
because they've been on the planet
um for a longer period of time but then
if they haven't got a job or not earning
as much then it's like okay what have
you been doing all of this time at your
big age it just it doesn't really I
don't know it's hot at all it's hard
though because you don't know people's
you know stories or backgrounds or yeah
I mean that just shows though that like
you are looking for money in a way it
might not be like that thing but because
they've reached a certain age where you
think they're not going to earn any more
money than this so it does mean you do
matter about it I feel personally for me
it's more an opinion of like what my
parents and what their expectations of
me are especially like obviously being a
woman living in a patriarchal society
like a lot of things are not really
geared towards women's safety or women
being able to earn as much much money as
men or being able to reach high CEO
positions and stuff talking about what
are you talking about our whole society
is geared towards women women make 70 to
80 percent of consumer buying decisions
our whole media is geared towards women
empowerment there's no men's empowerment
okay well I I don't know this is this
stick so I'm definitely wrong here but
I'm just saying in terms of like
um you know
um maybe more so Traditional Values then
and the way that like women
um see men as a way a type of security
or like a safety net so to speak so when
I'm looking at it from kind of that
perspective if we're really looking at a
man that is the example 35 who's earning
a lot less than a female that is a lot
younger than for me personally would be
questionable because then bringing that
home to my family and my family's like
okay so you're a young woman how is your
potential husband going to be able to
look after you and not only you but your
children do you think it's fair to ask
men to provide traditional outcomes when
we're not traditional women
it depends on um the couple like the the
couple has to be compatible together and
it depends on whether they um consider
or value societal values in their
relationships no so I'm just saying like
by and large like I know there's going
to be new you know what I mean I know
there's going to be Nuance but I'm
saying like by and large do you think
it's fair to to ask for traditional
outcomes when we're not traditional
women anymore
what is your definition of interesting
so so not being a traditional woman
anymore so I would say if you're not a
virgin like you're not a traditional
woman
because a traditional woman like
traditionally women were virgins when
they got married and a traditional
outcome is when the man is still
expected to protect and provide so it's
like we're asking for traditional
outcomes when we're not traditional
ourselves yeah because even in your
situation you were a bit traditional
yourself that because when you answer
that you you worry about what your
family's gonna think then why couldn't
you be the provider like if you truly
felt that way why couldn't you that it
doesn't matter if the man's a nurse and
earning like 20K or whatever why
couldn't you be the big you know the
main thing so even in yourself your
answers a bit uh traditional yeah I I
guess so I feel like that's maybe
because I value like my parents opinion
but then also I wouldn't want to be a
provider like I feel as though sometimes
um women they take on this big struggle
of yeah I have to do everything
um or they don't necessarily have the
support of like men
um in order to like reach their goals
and aspirations and they look talking
after everyone else but themselves so
it's just like oh I personally I
wouldn't prefer to like be like the main
earner in my household like I want to
put my feet up I want to relax like the
struggle life is not for me
modern women by and large offer that
because they also want Purity in Youth
and we don't offer either of those
things Purity I don't think is really a
major thing to be honest because we're
women really pure back then we don't
know 100 yeah yeah we can't guarantee
that I have a question for the men would
you want a girl that slept with a
hundred people no would you want a girl
that slept with 100 no but my answer is
probably different to what you expect
like because my reason is just like I
don't actually care that it's 100 people
it's just the fact that I wouldn't go
for that type of girl who is willing to
sleep with 100 people so it's not the
number that puts me off it's just then I
know that's that type of person like to
act but then you're basing her off the
number
it's based off of choices that she makes
yeah so like it's like if I was looking
at a guy and he cheated on every single
girl he'd been with death like I could
infer that he's a cheater so if a girl's
been sleeping around for the past decade
he can infer she's a hoe not exactly
like your your body can't does not
amount to who you are well yeah people
do change as well yeah but it amounts to
your decision-making abilities
but then that deter that those decision
abilities may be determined because of
like childhood trauma or like things
that that person has gone through or
experienced or experienced like a true
negative that's true experience but the
world doesn't owe you understanding yeah
so the guy the guy like when you come to
a guy he doesn't owe you understanding
and if you come to him and he can tell
you something around like I think it's
in his right to not want to date you
then I have a question do you think that
a male like for us being women do you
think uh men owe us respect
um I mean I think everyone deserves like
a basic level of like I don't even want
to say respects I guess respect is
earned but like human decency but I
think like you should be selective in
who you date and I think men have a
right to be selective and who they date
and if they don't want to date a girl
that slept around I think that's
perfectly fine and I wouldn't want my
brother to date a girl that's like bang
the whole football team
because the male can bang the whole
cheerleading team yeah because men and
women are different and because a man
has to become something in order to
sleep around
yeah he you're not gonna you're not
gonna okay you're not gonna sleep around
with like an overweight bomb
right you you forgot overweight bum
comes up to you you going on a date with
him
I don't know it depends on the
confidence
[Laughter]
Men have had the Head Start From that's
why I'm saying our generation is gonna
change things a lot because in terms of
women are going to be able to catch up a
lot more so women are going to be able
to catch up a lot more
um yeah I feel like we can't ignore
history when it comes to find when
you're considering Financial the
financial position of men and women you
can't ignore history I just get totally
sick of that
you know when it comes to like the
finances because I've worked in jobs and
I've earned the same as the men
and when they talk about all this pay
Gap and that the men have had it and the
women have had it as far as I'm
concerned there's no reason why a woman
can't go out there and get paid the same
money for is she saying qualified same
qualified same qualifications same job
same experience I've done it
I've done it and I've also got a pay
rise every year I've never ever worked I
had a man on the same role as me same
experience earned more than me so when
they and you're talking about the old
generation I'm the old generation but
what I'm trying to say here is this what
sector is this transport Management in
transport okay and it doesn't matter
where it is because wherever you go you
can get paid you're required to have a
certain level of qualification any job
you can go any job that a man can get
qualified at and get paid a woman who is
equally qualified equally experienced
and has the same manner when it comes to
working because that's what we've let
women down they're mannerisms when they
go in they're even going like oh you
know they're going too strong but if you
go in a job with the right frame of mind
and nowadays the women are more
qualified
from in my generation that's what you're
going to say the women are more
qualified in the old generation we
weren't that qualified and the Young
Generation they were qualified now so
there is no reason for people to say oh
but the men have got it now because
they've earned more that's rubbish
nowadays well especially for the new
generation because it's there for you on
the plate you've got it better than us
yeah so I don't understand like what
does that have to do with me today that
like some women were locked out of
Education before I was born how does
that affect me because even in these
environments let's say a woman has
managed to get to let's say a very
senior position it's still an
environment that is dominated by male
nurse especially white maleness so for
instance if you're a white woman and
you've now come into this space you have
to overcome the barrier of being a woman
in a male dominated space no I don't
okay so how would you how would you
adapt do you work hard you work hard
like that's what I said like every time
someone Billings their pay on the pay
Gap they're lazy honestly they're lazy
because the pay Gap doesn't exist when
you take in this is where you don't
understand when you take into account
personality differences between men and
women women don't ask for raises that's
the problem sixty percent of women have
never asked for a raise and you're going
to complain that you don't get paid the
same you don't ask for a raise that's
what I'm saying the environment a man
because this is an environment that men
have been in no it's a choice that's a
choice before women if I personally me
personally I would ask for a raise but
it's it's different because the it takes
confidence to ask for that confidence in
yourself and if you're in an environment
that wasn't even made for people like
you people like you for some women there
will be some of the there would be some
of the first people in that kind of
environment and they have to thrive in
that you have to overcome the barrier of
having to adapt in that environment
that's something a man doesn't have to
think one there are quotas okay so there
are specific quotas to give women jobs
over men men don't have any quotas so
working they don't need it no no because
why why do they why do we need a quota
do you not think women are qualified to
get the job on their own I didn't say
that no but that's what you're implying
by saying no no no no no no that's why I
said you can't ignore the history no
because the reason the question that's
an excuse that's an excuse I'm not
saying it's an excuse okay anyone can go
out and get any job they want nothing's
stopping us there's no law stopping us
and if anything there's incentives I
mean I've worked in a male dominate the
environment all my life
and sometimes you say I was the only
black woman supervisor black woman
manager
props and it never props to me it was a
job I didn't care whether I was black or
not I'm getting the money I'm getting
the same one as everybody else to me it
didn't matter whether I was black or not
it was a job and the men that got the
job I've got the job they earned the
same as me and every year I make sure I
got my pay rise the way they did and you
didn't and I had the same nature you
didn't make it no and the thing is and
the thing is with women I find that when
they go out like yes you're actually
that's a change I'm in a male
environment I'm with a load of meals so
yeah you know I mean I can hold my own I
can have a conversation I'm gonna dress
feminine but I'm gonna sustain my own
masculine but you see when I step out
the house and I get home to my man all
feminine oh submissive and that's what
the women fail to realize now that the
new generation because you can go out
there and you can do a job just as good
as a man and when you come home you
forget that you're a woman you're still
going like you're a man that's what the
men don't like I'm I didn't I didn't
everything curious insinuated I did it
I'm not insinuating I'm just saying I'm
speaking from experience because I don't
want to hear the excuse of oh because
you're a woman you've got to go in that
environment and act a certain way
rubbish because of your color rubbish
because of your sex rubbish because of
the pay rubbish because I've done it
and it's the norm I've done it so all we
need to do if you want to get paid more
the same way how you can speak up and
say oh my woman this and that speaker
must say excuse me but I'm doing pay
your eyes can I have my money this is
how hard I've worked this is what I
deserve and this is what my contract
says now that's what I'm saying that now
you can do that but it hasn't always
been like that no I'm older than you I'm
53 I'm retired so you can't say now you
can do that because I've been doing it
okay but you can't this is what I mean
you can't ignore the history okay but
before I'm history I'm I'm the history I
am the history are you ignoring history
I am 53 I am retired I am your history
so you can't tell me to forget about the
history
and before my history my mother done the
same job
if you're talking about the top sectors
because they're still for instance in if
you're talking about science if you're
talking about tech if you're talking
about engineering these sectors there's
still a lack of women why because the
women don't go and do it if there's a
lack of women go and do it I wanted to
be a bus driver there was lack of women
you know what I've done I didn't
complain said there's no women bus
drivers go and do it they have no
managers go and do it don't sit back
complaining that in these top sectors
nowadays you've got all the
qualifications you the young people you
can go University you can get degrees go
and do it you know what I mean women if
you want to do something but don't
complain about it change it like you
said women are doing it but the results
are still not the same not really
they're not doing nothing
women are the most educated but they
don't make more money because they have
a ton of debt and women don't make the
majority of workplace deaths where's the
equality where are the marches men are
women majority of workplace deaths they
do all of the hard jobs therefore they
get more money do you want to be a
plumber do you want to be a bricklayer
the only the only jobs you're seeing are
the the two percent of jobs like CEOs
power power positions hypothetically but
my dad was one of those top one percent
CEOs he worked 80 hours a week for 40
years do you want to do that I don't
most women don't they want to have kids
okay that's again that's why I said this
is you can't you can't mix the two
because you're saying women should focus
with what you're saying you're saying
women should focus on having kids and
for that reason they wouldn't be able to
do that 80 hours a week no I'm not
saying what women should and shouldn't
do I'm saying I don't like excuses no
because you are you're blaming you're
blaming the pay gap on being a woman I'm
not blaming them you're saying you're
saying we need to be aware you're saying
you're saying we need to be aware of our
history I'm saying that has nothing to
do with me today I was born in 2022.
there's nothing that is holding me back
as a woman if anything it's offered me
advantages because all the men hiring
are attracted to you
no I that's you you apply for a job
you're a pretty young girl most men that
hire you are going to be attracted to
you good to be young I guess I'll do it
all again
do you not believe that oh to be young
again no one in four women are on
antidepressants and on top of that how
can we say we were disadvantaged before
when we didn't have to fight in Wars
the men were the ones that had to go
fight in words we'll save my body my
choice all day but we'll never talk
about their body their choice when they
get drafted women the majority of women
didn't even want the right to vote
because it came with the responsibility
of getting drafted so most girls are
like I'm a chill in the kitchen and I
absolutely would chill in the kitchen if
that was the same thing today that's the
mindset that that's the mindset that she
had again I wouldn't say that the
mindset that I have is the mindset of
the majority but again like I said you
can't use that to you can't use that to
just dismiss what has happened like he
said he said men he said that men have
had their head start and it's been like
that since the dawn of time but now that
times are changing you guys are still
you are still placing the value of women
on fertility and in the sexual
Marketplace I did not say personal value
I said in the sexual Marketplace okay so
the meant the fact you mentioned that a
man had to do 80 hours a week why can't
a woman do that then that's what I'm
asking a woman and they choose not to
I'm telling you like I I watched my dad
work his whole I didn't know my dad
really until I was older I barely saw
him and I I most women would not sign up
for that they can't keep lawyers at
high-end law firms past like the age of
35 because they say screw this I have
all the money I want all I want now is a
family
they can't pay these women to stay
because after a certain age your looks
are starting to go you're what are you
doing this for after you make a certain
amount of money so again the thing
that's limiting women is well there is
what you just said they're personal
choices and I don't think it's limiting
women
I don't so if there's nothing stopping
us from doing anything today and more
women say hey I would rather stay home
or take a lower paying job that I like
instead of doing the shitty job that all
the men are doing why is that a bad
thing
you can't say personal choice because a
man doesn't have to make that choice yes
he does that's my point a man can make a
choice of do I want to go into education
which pays less or do I want to be a
plumber that pays more you mentioned at
35 women go off and that's when they go
and start their family a man could have
had a family up until that point he
doesn't have to make that choice that's
what I'm saying no he can he can be a
stay-at-home Dad if he wants to but you
can't get rid of our biological Roots he
can also make that choice he could go
get a sugar mama if I mean certain men
not everyone has that not all guys can
pull that off but but you see what I'm
saying he could he could do a 50 50
relationship there's nothing stopping us
from making these choices it's just
women don't want to work hard jobs
men do
as many women have got more choices now
and they're just using their excuses
they've got more choices than ever
they're more powerful than ever they've
got more rights more everything than
what I had in the past but what are the
outcomes
they're more unhappier than ever right
yeah one in four women are on
antidepressants women owned two-thirds
of the debt even though they make less
money 70 to 80 percent of consumer
decisions are made by women married
women are more likely to be divorced
three years after their promotion to CEO
levels compared to their male
counterparts
and the divorced men 70 to 80 percent of
the time I want to actually advocate for
me I show them that we're not
no it's it's interesting
um I don't is it so in the U.S
um I know if someone gets divorced and
they have a kid with a girl in certain
States they have to pay 25 of their
after-tax income per kid
um I don't think it's as bad here no no
is it similar or no I don't think it's
though it can be similar but I think
what the thing is I think the US is a
bit more Cutthroat yeah yeah in terms of
English law we go by Case by case and
there's more of uh there's a lot more
fairness I think from what I've seen so
far which is good because I mean in
America you have community property
states which are just
like completely just cut the house the
Assets in the middle who cares what
happened in the case yeah and that
that's horrible because some cases are
really unique and they deserve attention
but then you have Equity distribution
states in America some some states and
uh which is what you expect of the Lord
to look at every single case and uh yeah
the the one that I was involved in was
an equitable distribution state
so the fact is the ex-wife actually
didn't fulfill the factors
um so that actually what gained like
that worked in favor of my client what
does fulfill the factors mean so the
statutory factors for he was in the
state of Colorado and in the state of
Colorado you have statutory factors for
example yeah I don't know how how people
are going to take this but it is the
factors for example if she wants 50
percent
she will basically get whatever
percentage from the assets if we can uh
like compensate compensating for her
contribution to the marriage if she took
care of children there's a percentage if
she gave up things like home making
as opposed to his 50 does that make
sense yeah so she can it could be 70 you
know 20 yeah and like it it's crazy
because I guess in some states like the
courts are separate like the courts for
like child support and the divorce court
so when he went to child support like to
get child support they would just say oh
you weren't in the kid's life the last
six months but they don't put in the
fact that like she wasn't letting him be
mm-hmm yeah so it's kind of it's very
um especially in the US here I looked up
I I think they get like 13 to like 20
ish per kid if that was correct right
say on on a slightly slightly on a
tangent but similar topic uh fun fact
like one of my friends who studied in
law in the UK I actually asked him about
the topic of
um you know like prenups and I said like
you know it must be a good idea right
you're safeguarding yourself you're
safeguarding each person then you feel
like it's a little bit more comfortable
going into the relationship and I said
like surely that's like a good way to go
you know in a trusting way and he was
like actually like there are loopholes
just because you have a prenup does not
mean you are going to get away you know
without compensation so
um it might work a little bit better in
America but let's say in the rest of the
world that's that's not the case and
he's like if you're smart especially
like people who have
well from their family old family
they actually like when their kids get
married they actually like they don't
put things or assets under their
children's name for a reason because if
the woman tries to divorce the man and
try to get the assets they can't because
it's under the entire family rather than
under an individual so he was saying
like there are ways
that you can so you can put your
sister's name you can get your brother
so it's like you know like it's it's
it's not yours it's it's the family and
so if that's the way that something's
named then you that that you can kind of
get away with it but you cannot just say
well I've got prenup so this is pre yeah
and that's scary no it scares me it is
and it's hard because I'm very Pro
marriage in like a family sense but I
understand like why guys don't want to
get married you know it like makes sense
because I'm like if I have if I could
possibly lose this much of my assets I
wouldn't want to get married either if
the like the roles were reversed and
what's more terrifying is that you don't
even have to get married to get the same
treatment that's the you can't even
cohabit because it's horrible you can't
even it's like they legally twist their
arm like they say well you know what no
then let's not get married and they say
ah but if you live with her for this
many years it's like
I actually I don't know if anyone is
Canadian in the audience who might know
but actually I heard that in Canada
maybe I might be making this up but I
thought I heard that it doesn't you
don't even have to marry it if you've
been living with your partner for a
certain amount of years that
automatically that person can try and
get money from you I mean I don't I
don't know I don't know I think that's I
think they're that's true but I might be
wrong so if anyone if I'm wrong please
correct me nice guy or they want this
thing and then they get it and they're
like I said it's a bit too nice guys we
wouldn't hate that
no I say
um player you know we like player and we
like to speak it's like a mix you know
you need to mix otherwise it's going to
be too boring or too how do you say too
traumatized because players you know
they can be a bit narcissist and they
can be a bit traumatic so it's a bit
it's about it makes about balance if you
are too much this or too much that of
course we get it like uh okay so can I
say as a man right that
that perfect balanced man that you're
looking for doesn't exist I know and so
you you having that in your head and I
think that's a lot of the time why women
get disappointed with men because
they've created this actual man in their
head that actually doesn't exist right
and so you're looking for this man and
you think oh that's the one that's like
he doesn't exist no woman has found the
quote-unquote perfect man yet they're
looking for him though and I think
that's because you guys have been sold a
Disney version of what um relationships
are you know like um they're just good
men or and good women right out there
and I think that this whole oh a man
should be this we want this we want that
he's got to be he's got to have an edge
to him but then he's got to be nice and
he's got to be loyal but then he's got
to be a homemaker but then he can't be
too now is that it's like how this list
is like how long like what what is this
list how it is the list from Men about
women our list is very simple um tell us
don't talk too much okay be cooperative
uh be a good mother if you if you've got
if you've got children
um
and and cooperate like talk too much
what
because because we don't because men
like peace
no women don't like these women don't
like peace I don't I I generally don't
think women like peace I think once
women get peace they get bored I think
women like excitement
yeah I think they like something a
little bit like a little bit more edgy a
little bit more exciting because if you
give one if you give a woman too much
peace she's like oh this is a little bit
boring whereas men will be happy to be
bored for the rest of their life chill
with a woman have this woman as their
woman and be like all right cool this is
my woman for rest of her life
but there's like I never met a guy that
has both because this guy that is very
sweet that was my seven year uh
relationship my ex and then I met
another guy for a year and a half and he
gave me all that excitement and then
trauma and right
so this is not me normal so why did you
so with this sorry if you don't mind me
asking so the seven year guy what was
bad about that like was he what was bad
about that relationship it's a great guy
like when it comes to heart like he's a
great human you know is a good heart I
just feel like he would make me jealous
on purpose like in front of me I don't
know why you know like I was like what
the [ __ ] I feel like it was probably
insecure
um and that's your problem and if you
want to talk about it let's talk about
it I'm I'm here to listen but I'm not
here to experience your pain or
triggering your frustrations you know if
you get triggered don't put it on me
um so yeah he was making me jealous and
then on my birthday for example I
actually got traumatized because uh
honestly so he was next to me and a girl
was next to him and he was talking to
her I don't mind talk who the [ __ ] you
want but then he was putting sounded
like you minded
like you did mine because that's what
I'm telling you right now is because he
was talking to her and he was putting
his hand on her leg and it was like glue
on his hand he didn't just touch and you
know took off it just let his hand there
like had glue for five minutes and then
I pinched myself and on my birthday I
just felt like
what the [ __ ] you know sorry
oh sorry
[Music]
wow
I didn't mean to like make you tell that
story and like get upset
it's my birthday you know it's your day
it's a day that you cannot forget you
know because you're gonna always
remember and
[Music]
it's hard when it's it's situations like
that that
make you think about just other
situations because seven years is a long
time and if I were you I'd be like I'm
for the streets too forget him I'm out
here
but that was not my relationship with
seven years that I had with my ex that
was the relationship that I had recently
for a year okay okay yeah because that
was the extreme the player that I was
talking and the other one that was so
sweet so loyal so good because they are
good really good ones out there that was
with the seven years yeah I just broke
up with him because I moved to London
and I was in Switzerland with him yeah
uh but yeah definitely I agree with that
why didn't you marry him then you would
take it for seven years because I don't
want to marry you no I don't want to
marry no I want to have a family I want
to marry but I wanna take care of my mom
first my mom is my baby so I wanna
because on my career
and I want to provide for me and for my
mom
and then
you know get married and get a family
okay that's my plan really what if and I
I hope like you don't feel like the
spotlight's on you this is like just a
general question if anybody was in that
situation that had to take care of a
parent what if there was someone that
came into your life that was like I will
stand behind you no matter what it is
that you have to do and I will be there
for you to help you take care of your
mother whatever it is no matter if I'm
here if I'm away would you reconsider
like if your boyfriend for seven years
was like I'll I'll move to London with
you I will help you take care of your
mother like I'm here for the long run
would you have stayed with him
yes but he didn't want to oh he didn't
want to move to London because he came
here though to experience the life and
he didn't like you think he thought he
was too chaos chaotic chaotic do you
ever worry about running out of time to
get married like it might be harder if
you wait longer I thought about that too
especially if you want to have like a
family and stuff so this manifestation
thing can I just like bring it back like
this whole manifestation Law of
Attraction thing sounds great um on
paper but statistically when you look at
it like Pearl said like over 30 and
you're less likely to like get married
and stuff like that and the thing is um
as a man it's very interesting that um I
think like Echo Chambers are a thing
right so
I think when one of the reasons why men
get
um like attacked when they speak the
truth about statistics is because women
live in Echo Chambers amongst women so
women can sit amongst other women and
say yay manifest him girl you know you
the law of attraction is great like you
don't worry he's coming you're you're
guys coming it's like and men are like
what the hell are they talking about
like like get on like because as men
when we want to do something we start
doing it we start like making the plans
to do something right and it's like if
you don't make plans to do something and
thinking you can like kind of wish it
into existence really and truly nine
times out of ten nothing actually gets
done
so this whole thing of uh oh yeah I wish
him into existence and the law of
attraction in the right time blah blah
blah it's hard for men to hear that
because that table right there wasn't
wishing to existence do you know I mean
it was a man said I need to make a table
and I'm gonna make a table I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna think about it and think
yeah
why does a woman need a man that's what
I mean they just don't realize it yet
because you try surviving on your own
without a man you cannot wake up in the
morning and go through your whole day
without having to rely on a man for
something like what
by everything around us wherever you go
you get your petrol wherever you go and
you get the bus whether you the the the
the clothes that you wear in the shop
the designer you cannot get through life
without a man man built the world
like they they do all of the hard jobs
in society everything that makes the
infrastructure run I'm not saying we
don't need men that's not my view at all
but I just feel like
this is what this is like that term left
over I feel like the things you're
saying and the over-reliance on men
that's what perpetuates that view
because it makes it seem like a woman
literally can't survive without a man
and I feel like you're linking that like
one thing you mentioned earlier you said
that there's a link between divorce
rates and um when women were able to get
access to birth control and I feel like
in terms of marriage like when you're
when you're equating marriage with
that's when a woman's gonna have kids
and she's gonna take some of the man's
income in that sense I feel like
um I've lost my point now I forgot what
I said today a lot of I feel like
there's a lot of feelings is there any
do you come from a place of logic or is
this all feeling
what do you think his feeling so what do
you think is feeling no because you say
I feel like I feel like I feel like so I
was just wondering if you're saying that
I do want me to say no no I don't know
I'm is it all feeling if you tell me
your feeling then I don't think he's
feeling this is what I mean I feel like
women have what do you want me to say
sorry
and when young people look at it like oh
there's something wrong being being a
housewife wait till you're 35 and you're
on your own and there's no man and it's
just you and your pets and then you're
gonna think I've got my degree I've
traveled I've done this I've got my
house I've got my business who are you
going to travel with your old friends
your old female friends because nobody
of any status is going to want to travel
with you especially if you've got
children so you might think that things
were different back in the day but
things were actually better back in the
day because people got married I'm one
person I believe until death do you part
you shouldn't be allowed to get divorced
somebody should have to die before you
get divorced because that's what it says
till death do you part and if more
people were into marriage thinking you
know what get counseling let me go and
do this talk to my elders talk to my
parents then get more successful
marriages and it wouldn't seem so bad as
a young person
I agree with you I'm not a Gates
marriage I don't tell you as a father I
know from raising my son that he needs
both me and his mother in his life so I
so when someone who hasn't had children
is telling me Oh no kids don't need
they're both their parents I find it
laughable because because I tell you
something most parents will tell you
that they know that their child needs
both parents in their life for you to
say something like that makes no sense
to me as a parent it doesn't make any
sense I have kids in my family that will
raise single parents and whatever or
some kids in care and stuff like that I
feel like it's laughable that you just
said oh my my life is this so you're
wrong
he's saying my life is this and stats
back it up statistics about what the
results are at the end of this because
the way you're going it's just like I
believe what I believe regardless of any
stats so you could see whatever stat and
you're still going to think what you
think yeah because I think you can't
generalize anything in the world I don't
think anything can be generalized
like until SEO therapist giving specific
advice like you have to generate I think
people are too individual to even you
said you can't generally you can't say
women are this you can't say so-and-so
is out you can't say children prefer
milk
you can't say anything what do you mean
you can't generate I never I don't say
anything I don't say women of this or
dogs of that or whatever is this I just
say that thing there is this and that's
it and I don't feel I don't I don't have
a life do dogs bark
so now you would just argue just to be
right in in a conversation because you
know dogs bark but for you to say oh
some don't it's like you know that
that's what then you can't argue
anything you can't argue yeah like if
you don't if you can't generalize at all
then you can't argue anything yeah
I'll take that back and I will just say
you can't generalize men and women and
Families